[Música]
[Aplausos]
imágenes
imaginemos una situación
llegar al trabajo
grados
yonath
contra su hijo no se les dan
completamente tratando
fue
si acaso se sentarían
recuerda con quien sin coche a nosotros
yo
imagina si demuestras extensiones
y los alumnos antes
quiere
está con sus dientes
y aumentada
bien
y en esa hora le dicen
antes que sacarse adelante
bien
[Música]
este hombre había pasado
ahora imaginemos gracias
de chicos en diferentes partes del mundo
con diferentes técnicas
viento de ejércitos
[Música]
desde mal
estas consonantes intensivos
por ciento
y el otro mundo
estaba sentada
eso comunicantes diferentes
para ser
la verdad
la seda americana
de hoy en día
ya sé
trabajando en el plan esas citas con
situaciones
también méxico también aquí
[Música]
después
que entender muy importante es que las
tecnologías están fabulosas
y vamos a utilizar
[Música]
a la plataforma
pues para que las carillas
habitaciones
muchas cosas los entornos virtuales y
nacionales
y herramientas
[Música]
cosas
cuidado
[Música]
y entonces
como una plataforma
entonces cada vez más a ocurrir
dónde
eso
[Música]
ahora no practicar como solía ser
y pareciera que la tecnología nos supera
sí
y entonces
después empezamos a ver cuáles elementos
importantes
cosas que los actores los fiscales de
inversiones tridimensionales y de esa
manera
y es ahí donde los puntos importantes
para las elecciones sino únicamente
decir
cuándo
hola
y para ser aplicadas
entonces
las estaciones
y bueno
[Música]
la experiencia en todos es
el espacio
ah
y puedes terminar cosas
en efecto sí
encontramos el proceso de inversión
inversión
es importante que genera la situación es
decir
cuál sería la forma de hacer turnos
primero
estará la prevención
para determinar desde qué vamos a
empezar
eso no lo sé
estaba consciente
a la par de esas comisiones de inversión
de que un agente virtual
cuándo
de jóvenes donde la sensación de que
este cosas desde que estoy aquí y
físicamente
con elementos virtuales
y luego la cantidad de 4 12
ya que me siento tan tan
sí
[Música]
y las enfermedades
con una inversión de interaction único
no no
[Música]
con esa actividad
clínicamente
y sin de emoción
actividad
y ahora
en la cuestión
como pasa
pues la cuestión de la narración
y una grabación donde es entrenada sea
amigo
de este área
si bien es que mientras conoces
qué es
tiene
un campo como importante
es en donde exigió que este proceso de
percepción
gracias
un proceso distinto de definiciones
las tics de peligro
[Música]
los entornos digitales tradicionales y
presidenciales
y les digo
nuestra cuenta de la sensación de
interés
cómo
parece una vara
es completamente historia
[Música]
a través de esa percepción
ya no
[Música]
y entonces esas cosas siguientes que no
se ven
las tradicionales
es muy importante
no debemos decir divertido cambiar
muchos procesos de aprendizaje
también estábamos
me fascina la parte virtual
o
[Música]
o sea así que no tenemos esas cuestiones
de donde la imaginación
podemos
[Música]
con todo esto
dónde
bueno
eso te lo dejan y muchas gracias
[Aplausos]